so we are king as a bank i'm julie
technisat jessica ka and we are here at
film courage interactive we just got
finished watching John Paul Rises when
our fantasy girl and I just have to say
this whole experience is really
overwhelming and we've just met so many
great people i mean i think Julie's
going to cry Karen and David of course
Dennis Peters we saw their course though
um Mary incur we saw Phil Calderon who
else'll Nathan Cole Gregor Collins has
been doing scary Gregor come I wouldn't
say scary i was very scary else and then
she would say hands um oh and the
gentleman who does father and son did
father and son yes we have to meet out
front you know why I really miss
actually besides fellow holbrook sherry
candler yeah we're just we're sure did
we miss her because this is she kind of
shy be here anyway we got to see all of
our idols except for sharing candler so
that's not some day some day